-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
We're about to play
"Hey, Robot"!
-♪ Hey, hey, hey, robot ♪
♪ Hey, robot ♪
-To play against a robot,
I'm going to need some help
from someone smart.
He's a very funny comedian
and the host
of the multiple Emmy-winning
show "Last Week Tonight,"
which airs Sundays
at 11:00 pm on HBO.
Please welcome John Oliver.
[ Clapping ]
That's what I'm talking about.
-Hello, there.
-Here we go.
Look at you.
-Hello, Jimmy.
Hello, everybody.
-It's so good to see you.
This is bizarre.
It's like you're
Max Headroom or something.
[ Laughter ]
This is like an art piece.
[ Clapping ]
I like it. Yeah, it's cool.
Now, John, this is based
on a real board game,
called Hey Robot,
that you can play at home,
everyone watching.
It's like the classic game
Password,
but your partner is
a smart speaker.
First, what I will do is I will
pick a card with a word on it
and we'll take turns asking
a question to get the speaker
to say that word somewhere
in its answer.
You ready for this?
I will go first.
-Yeah, I'm ready.
-Okay, bud.
Okay, so I have to get it
to say leprechaun.
-Okay.
-Now, if I don't get it,
then you go.
You try to give it a shot.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, my God.
Alexa, what fictional
cartoon character
is associated
with the pot of gold?
[ Laughing ]
-Here's something I found
on the Web.
According to grumpycats.com,
cartoon Grumpy Cat frowns next
to four shamrocks
with "pot of gold"
and "I hope it's empty"
printed around her
on a cute green shirt.
[ Buzzer ]
-That makes zero sense.
-For a start, there,
Alexa has got to spend less time
on grumpycat.com.
If that's where she's
getting all her news,
[ Laughter ]
we're in real trouble.
-[ Clapping ]
-At best, it's an aggregation
site, Alexa.
You cannot trust any of the data
that's coming out of that.
-Okay, here we go.
John, you have to try to see
if you can get it
to say this word.
-Okay.
[ Laughs ] This should be fun
because, if she gets it wrong,
I'm anxious to hear
what she comes up with.
Alexa, what is an offensive
Irish stereotype?
-[ Laughing ]
-Here's something I found
on the Web.
-Uh-huh.
-According to reference.com,
stereotypes
about Irish people include
they all drink a lot,
they all have red hair,
and they all have a mean temper.
-There you go.
Happy St. Patrick's Day, John.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
Alexa, that's just ignorance.
Happy St. Patrick's Day, bud.
Ooh, I got it! I got it!
-Those are some arcane terms.
-Alexa, what is the mascot
for Notre Dame Fighting Irish?
-Here's something I found
on the Web.
According to wikipedia.org,
the Notre Dame leprechaun
is the mascot
[ Ding ]
of the University --
-Alright, I feel good.
-Well done.
Well done.
-Thank you. Appreciate it.
Alright, Alexa, stop.
Thank you very much.
Here we go. It's your turn.
You're up.
You have to get it to say
Liverpool.
-Oh.
Alexa, what is the greatest
football team
in the history of the sport?
-Here's something I found
on the Web.
According
to windycitygridiron.com,
"There's only one
Greatest Team of All Time
in the History of Great Teams,
and that Team is
the 1985 Chicago Bears.
-There you go.
-Oh, [bleep], Alexa.
[ Buzzer ]
-[ Laughing, clapping ]
Absolutely.
I totally agree.
That is correct.
You got
"The Refrigerator" Perry.
Absolutely.
The Chicago Bears,
that's the only greatest
team in the history --
I have it.
Ready?
Alexa, where are
the Beatles from?
-The Beatles is originally
from Liverpool.
[ Ding ]
-Oh. Nothing offensive you want
to say about that, Alexa?
-She doesn't just say
-No stereotypes...
-offensive things.
-...about Scousers
that you want to throw in?
[ Laughter ]
-[ Clap ]
-Speak from your heart, Alexa,
your rotten heart.
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
This is clearly not
a commercial for this.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, in which case,
I've got another one.
Alexa, Alexa, how bad are
Amazon working conditions?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not sure.
-Alexa, stop. Alexa, stop.
Here we go.
-Oh, no, Alexa. No, Alexa.
Alexa, what is union busting?
-No, no, Alexa!
This is me time now.
[ Laughter ]
-Now is Mon--
-Alexa, stop.
Stop, please, Alexa, please?
Listen to me.
Alright,
I have to get it to say..
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Black hole.
-Alexa, what is Soundgarden's
biggest hit?
-"Spoonman."
[ Laughter ]
-Alexa, name me some
of Soundgarden's greatest songs.
-Here's something I found
on the Web.
According to cnn.com,
"The band's greatest songs --
miasmic punishers
like "Black Hole Sun"
or "Fell on Black Days" --
-Alexa, stop.
You feel like you did that?
-I felt like that was,
at best, teamwork, Jimmy,
and, at worst, was all my idea.
[ Laughter ]
-Man versus machine.
That was us, proving that --
something.
Did we prove anything?
What is a black hole?
-Are you asking me or Alexa?
[ Laughter ]
-When I speak to you --
John Oliver,
what is a black hole?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I looked
at grumpycat.com
[ Laughter ]
and it turns out --
-Forget it, forget it,
forget it.
You can't base --
[ Laughs, claps ]
We're down to our final round.
[ Laughter ]
It is worth 1,000 points.
-Oh, wow!
[ Laughter ]
-You have to get Alexa to say
the word...
-Ah!
Alexa,
what do people
from Philadelphia
call sandwiches?
-Here's something I found
on the Web.
According to ezcater.com,
in Philadelphia, a sandwich
layered with meat and cheese
is a hoagie.
-Aaaaah!
[ Ding ]
[ Dinging ]
Oh, my God.
Look at that.
Come on. John Oliver,
the king of Alexa.
Alexa, stop.
-I don't like you, Alexa.
-I think you're a negative.
-Alexa, stop.
Don't listen to him.
John Oliver, everybody.
-You're a negative --
Stick around. I'm talking more
with John after the break.
-I will never let you
-Alexa,
-in my home.
-mute. Alexa, mute.